can i ask you about the quarantine
situation we've had more countries added
today i mean
to be fair smaller countries but
nevertheless i mean belgium
it is a concern it raises questions of
course as to whether we're going to see
bigger
tourist destinations like france
involved in
in the next step here i mean
what is your understanding of the
situation because you've got to be
across this surely
this has a big economic impact
it does i think look it's it's a tricky
situation what i can say to people
is we're in the midst of a global
pandemic and that means there is always
the risk of disruption to travel plans
and people need to bear that in mind
it's the right thing though for us to do
to keep
everything under review on a constant
basis talking with our scientists our
medical
advisors and if we need to take action
as you've seen overnight we will of
course
not hesitate to do that and we're doing
that to protect people's health
um but in the meantime you know people
should just continue to
to look at the guidance and make a
decision and take
everything into account themselves and
make a decision that they think is best
you're out and about today talking about
the amount of money that government has
has thrown into the project to try and
keep everything ticking along as
as best you can it do you get frustrated
when obviously there has to be a balance
between health
and economic health i mean this is a
a real step backwards isn't it when we
you know you
you do what you can but then we're sort
of really crippling the tourist industry
again
well i think we put a lot of uh support
in place to help the tourist industry
drive our recovery
uh out of this crisis i'm in scotland
today you know scotland is one of our
power brands when it comes
to tourism in the united kingdom i want
scotland to play a key part of our
recovery
so if you look at the vat reduction
we've put in place for the tourism
hospitality sector initiatives like eat
out
to help out you know all of those things
help protect the two million
plus jobs of people who work in that
industry
and you know i think we can slowly see
the benefits of that on the ground
um so i think we are actually making
steps forward with the support we put in
place
where are we in terms of things like
bounce back loans i know that's been one
of the
uh one of the the big sort of flag
waving events i know for a lot of
companies
will very much have welcomed it but
there is concern that
for other companies and smaller
companies it's just adding to an
ever-growing debt
and and some reports saying well up to
40 percent of those bounce-back loans
could never be paid back i know there's
lots of different reports uh out there
on on different estimates and what you
know what we do know is over
a million businesses give or take have
been able to receive bounce back loans
on average about 30 000 pounds they've
done in a way that should be
measured it's about a quarter of annual
turnover so it's affordable for them and
for the first year
no one has to pay anything back and and
after that uh there's a five-year period
for people to pay the loans back the
interest rate is very attractive at two
and a half
percent so we've designed these loans
particularly to to really help support
our small businesses
they've made i think a really
significant difference to businesses up
and down the country
helping them get through that difficult
period of the last few months when many
of them
were told to close but now that they're
reopened in a covered secure way
and they can look forward and that's why
it's important slowly as our economy
returns to normal we return to doing the
things
that we all enjoy doing and by doing
that we can
you know we can make sure that we try
and protect the millions of jobs that
are involved in all those industries
and realize that the new normal is one
that is safe you know we can
combat the virus continue to do things
in a way that is covered secure
but also get our economy uh back to
normal again and then in doing so
help protect as many jobs as possible
but when when you plan through all of
these sort of things
and heaven knows it must be incredibly
difficult
but you know talking about 30 000 pounds
on average but it's adding up to
billions upon billions of pounds
in total i mean what sort of percentage
of that have you
set aside to say right we're not going
to get this back
actually the office for national
statistics and others will make a
uh an evaluation of that and make an
adjustment for that on our account
i remain optimistic that if we can
actually drive our economic recovery
forward
then you know we we should be able to
recover a large amount of the loans that
we have
put out there the single best way to do
that is to make sure we get our economy
going
again but you know are some of those
loans going to be written off absolutely
we've
been very clear we won't be able to save
every single job every single business
despite the unprecedented amount of
support that we've put in place
but looking forward with our plan for
jobs tourism is a part of that and the
various other measures
we've put in place for example the
kickstart scheme to support
young people who are at risk of being
unemployed into new jobs supporting
apprenticeships for example
you know all those initiatives i think
will make a difference and help ensure
that as we
exit the acute phase of this crisis you
know we can slowly rebuild our economy
if people regain the confidence they had
and i think that that is the most
important thing for us all now to focus
on
look i i don't think anyone could
underestimate
how difficult to position you put in and
that would apply to you know
who was in government at the time of
something like this
but you're now faced with a situation
where i mean for example
something like the furlough scheme which
undoubtedly has been a lifeline to a lot
of people but now
who do you listen to moving forward
because there are some people
saying the furlough scheme has and is
protecting
unproductive jobs whilst others are
saying
the phasing out of the furlough scheme
is going to put
tens if not hundreds of thousands of
people out of work
who do you listen to when moving forward
on a scheme like that
we're right it's it's one of the most
difficult decisions that i've had to
make in this job
but if you look at it from start to
finish stephen
the government will have been stepping
in to help pay people's wages for almost
eight months which is an extraordinarily
long
period of time and i think most
reasonable people would look at that and
say
that's not something that is obviously
sustainable in the long run and
in common with many other countries
around the world their versions of this
are all coming to an end towards the end
of this year
that said we've still got support in
place the jobs retention bonus
will mean that for every employee that a
company is able to bring back from
furlough successfully employ them
through to january of next year they
will receive a thousand pounds bonus
which actually for the wages of most
people who have been furloughed will
make a significant difference especially
to those smaller companies
but i don't think it's fair to extend
this indefinitely it's not third of the
people on it we shouldn't
pretend that there is in every case a
job for someone to go back to
we actually should be helping them
prepare for their new opportunity
that they they should be looking for and
that's what our plan for jobs does and
i'm seeing that in action today in
scotland
but providing support for new
apprenticeships new training
jobs in the tourism industry this is
what we need to do now it's to look
forward
provide the opportunities for tomorrow
yes there is hardship ahead
for many people we know that but they
shouldn't be left without hope and i
think our plan for jobs provides that
hope
and that's what we can now do together
as we look forward to the future then
hopefully the economy picking up and
things getting back to
a new normal of some description or
other
when you sit down with a calculator at
night what sort of figures are we
totaling here i mean
what is what is the the cost of this so
far
right i do sit there with my calculator
at night um it
it's gonna this year we will borrow a
significant amount
of money to help pay for the various
measures that we've put in place i do
believe that's the right thing to do and
most independent economic commentators
agree with that as well
in a situation like this we should act
uh with boldness
to try and preserve as much of what we
call the productive capacity of our
economy for the long run
you know that said without question the
virus has taken a toll on our economy
and that will have a long run impact
over the next few years
our economy will likely be a bit smaller
than it otherwise would have been
and that obviously has implications for
you know what we can afford to do
our public finances have taken a
significant hit and over the medium term
we'll obviously need
to put our public finances on a
sustainable footing we can't continue
uh to operate in a way that we've done
this year in crisis mode
and that will require some difficult
decisions down the line and
i'm obviously prepared to make those
difficult decisions i think there will
be the right things to do
for the country i think all of us want
to see you know our strong economy
restored and that's the plan that we'll
set out
at the appropriate time
look we're out of time so i'm being
yelled at by my producers as you can
imagine but i've got to ask you i mean
instability and uncertainty are the two
key things
the econo the economy doesn't like um
can the economy cope in the next 24
months or so with
the effects of the pandemic and what
looks like a no deal brexit next year
well i think on on brexit as you would
have heard recent reports you know we
remain confident that it's possible to
get a deal
in september i think we've made good
progress on
lots of different areas in the
negotiations on trading goods
energy on transport social security
cooperation the structure of the deal
so there's been lots of good progress
you can see that it's possible that said
there do remain some considerable gaps
uh notified on things like fisheries uh
and so
there's there's work to do but we remain
very committed to working through those
remaining issues with our european
friends and allies and hopefully we can
conclude a deal but regardless one way
or another we will have certainty
and as you've seen from our
announcements elsewhere today on
helping businesses in northern ireland
we're making preparations
uh so that we can embrace our future
with confidence